يتوقع الناس أنه يمكن أن
يصل إلى النقطة التي سيتمكن فيها كل شخص
من حمل الهاتف
في حقيبته أو على وركه أو
أيًا كان ، وأن كل من يريد
واحدًا سيتم تقديمه.
يقوم
أشخاص جدد بإجراء مكالمات من
سياراتهم لعقود من الزمن ، بعض الأشخاص
حتى الآن قد حدت التكنولوجيا من
عدد الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم استخدامها حتى
في مدينة كبيرة مثل نيويورك ، ولا يمكن لأكثر
من عشرين شخصًا استخدام الهواتف
المحمولة في وقت واحد  هولت لديك
هوائي واحد ينتقل إلى
منطقة معينة وإذا كان
لديك 20 قناة فقط لأغراض الوصف ،
فيمكن لـ 20 شخصًا فقط التحدث في أي وقت ولكن
الآن بفضل الاتصالات
الخلوية ، قد تصل الهواتف المحمولة قريبًا إلى
الجماهير
في الهاتف الخلوي ماذا  لقد فعلنا ذلك هو أننا قمنا
بتقسيم منطقة إلى أجزاء من الخلايا نسميها
، ولكل خلية هوائي
عليها وتنقل بطاقة منخفضة جدًا
في تلك الخلية ،
لذا ما يحدث هو أنك تقود y
سيارتنا وتنتقل من الخلية الواحدة إلى
الخلية التالية ، يتم تسليم مكالمتك من
الخلية الأولى إلى الخلية الثانية ،
وتلتقط قناة جديدة في الخلية الثانية
ويتم تحرير القناة الأصلية التي كانت لديك
في الأولى من أجل جديد  عميل
قادم إلى المنطقة ،
يقوم نظام كمبيوتر متطور بتوجيه
العملية برمتها بإعادة استخدام القنوات التي
يقول المسؤول الرئيسي عنها عندما يبدأ النظام
في شيكاغو بعد حوالي عام من الآن
، سيتمكن كل من يريد هاتفًا محمولًا من الحصول على هاتف
مقابل حوالي
مائتي  دولار شهريًا ووفقًا لما ذكره
راسل موني من لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية ، فإن الإمكانات
غير محدودة يتوقع الناس
أنها يمكن أن تصل إلى درجة أن
كل شخص سيكون قادرًا على حمل
هاتف في حقيبته أو
على وركه أو أيًا كان
يريد أن يتم تقديمه ،
أنا جيف لوك سي إن إن في شيكاغو
[موسيقى]